is that right
cutter penny
that's his real name
it's really it's Roman yeah
came from the rodeo
what absolutely sure did did it not no
it did my dad was a bull rider mom was a
barrel racer that's how you have the
name cutter so I got my name cutter yeah
the cowboy name it's a cowboy yeah my my
parents really thought I was gonna
become a cowboy named Dallas Texas it
was like before like the big boom some
little suburb outside of Dallas and uh
cut array that's what they were gonna
chant from them
things things went with crooked didn't
they I guess so
penny where are you from I grew up in La
I'm from North Hollywood I went to
middle school here I grew up here yeah
what were your childhoods like
just a quick little overview
solid C minus childhood okay
um I grew up in Orange County and my dad
had substance abuse issues my entire
life and my mom was dealing with that
and then my parents actually passed away
when I was a teenager yeah sure thank
you my dad he had a heart attack when I
was 15 and then my mom got sick when I
was 16 and then I was her full-time
caretaker until I graduated high school
right after high school when she passed
away when I was 18. before that happened
how would you describe I mean like any
abuse or anything like that
no I wouldn't say abuse no I just had
having a dad who's an addict it's not
ideal it was intense yeah I mean there
was a lot of he was in rehab and not in
rehab anymore when he was not in rehab
it was tough but also being in rehab is
tough so it was just a lot of
back and forth in him really struggling
and trying to be there for my family and
me but just him being too sick
your childhood how would you describe it
um it Led Led to me becoming a gifted
and talented kid
for all those gifted and talented kids
out there I think they understand what
that means burnt out yeah my mom has a
disease called a multifocal sensory
motor peripheral neuropathy I think I
said that right wow um it's related to
Ms it deteriorates the muscle and nerve
system goes in deadens the nerves and
then from there it eats away at the
muscles
um
my parents were pretty much separated
from most of my childhood so I think
there was just a lot of
really like grown-up adult stuff I had
to you know comprehend the best I could
as a kid and then so I think like second
grade I was like I'm gonna go to college
for free on a scholarship I don't think
most second graders really like create
that goal
um
but I did
um
and then yeah I I went off to see I
started Community College 13. uh got a
full ride at 15 had this near-death
experience
17 dropped out became an actor moved out
to LA
and then got kinky so is that how you
guys met
acting your brother yeah in an acting
class yeah yeah
um did you discover that you had a
a kink or a fetish when did I discovered
a king or finish
um I was in high school with an ex and
we would tie each other up with Scholars
did you know that I think so scarves
yeah with scarves like we were just
doing like bondage with each other
um and that's kind of when I figured
this out I was like oh I like this stuff
um it's fun it is fun and also a lot of
like
fan fiction from Tumblr
yeah
how did you get into this lifestyle uh
how did I get into it
um so I was in the entertainment
industry in Dallas and uh I remember
reading something in some sort of
article that Plano which is near Dallas
is like the highest per capita of
swingers than any other city in the US
which I thought was pretty interesting
yeah North Dallas go figure
um and so swingers and alternative
Lifestyles and things like that are
really really common in the
entertainment world out there and so you
know became aware of it but it wasn't
really my thing
uh moved out to LA and
um
I was living out of my car at the time
got sick and uh like a flu or something
and stayed in with someone and logged
back in FetLife one day and uh
discovered that there was this really
cheap party called Tim before 10 at this
Oregon North Hollywood and
I was like I'm feeling better I got 10
bucks I can spare let me go check this
out and I walked through the doors and I
was like ah this is this is where it is
you know for so long people thought um
but I was gay and I was like no that's
not it I don't know what I am but it's
not that uh my family my mom every every
year every year would take us out to
like IHOP or something and be like it's
okay to be gay and I'm like oh I love
that Mom it's not me though it's not me
though I was like well you just
something just like something wasn't
clicking and never could figure
something's foggy you didn't know what
it was and yeah it was always a
conversation in the holidays of like
what my sexuality was
and everyone was like I had once I was
like it's okay to be gay we'll still
love you and then the other side is like
we'll still love you but we'll make fun
of you for it oh my God what's being in
the South yeah
um
and it yeah turns out it's not that but
I'm instead I I'm kinky you're kinky I'm
kinky I was without being too nosy how
does it impact your relationship with
each other
all of it a lot of it with each other
yeah oh I mean it's our lifestyle yeah
some people do it like in the bedroom
yeah
um we're more of a 24 7 power exchange
kind of pretty much yeah yeah and Carter
you actually
instructs people on on to explain what
you do yeah so for a time that that
organization I went I went to I fell in
love with it I had a really big
background in volunteering and running
organizations and it fell in hard times
and they were looking for people to step
up into leadership type positions so I
became the volunteer coordinator then
after that I went on to the board doing
Special Projects it closed for a time
it's like my whole thing was going in
there trying to get it reopened for the
community so people can come back
together again and then from there I
actually became I don't never liked this
title but I ended up becoming the CEO of
the organization
um and so really the whole purpose was
to offer a space so that people can come
in and and explore radical sexual
Freedom
um
around BDSM and kink and things like
that so a lot of that just looked like
doing one-on-one classes or finding
presenters who could come in and teach
um and just skillshare peer-to-peer
skill sharing that's what a lot of it
was and then I would travel to different
conferences and attend workshops myself
and meet some really wonderful people so
that's what I did for
four or five years
um
what do you do for a career
yeah as a career I was able to take like
my experience as an actor it kind of
fill into production and production took
all of that behind the camera working in
front of the camera work and combine
that with my sex positive work that I
was doing and I became an intimacy
coordinator where I advocate for talent
when they're doing uh simulated sex
nudity or intimate scenes for TV and
film really yeah it's interesting how
your
all your interests and all your careers
are all kind of related yeah it's great
isn't it it's really nice it was so I
was on a
like a religious retreat when I found
out about intimacy coordinating I was
like that's my that's it that's perfect
for me yeah that's what I want to do and
I pursued that and um it's been it's
just it's just so cool doing that line
of work helping people and
um
helping them discover boundaries like
you could be sex positive and yet not be
you know into Kink or not being to be
descent or polyamory or whatever it is
you know sex positivity doesn't require
any of that and so it's just really cool
to to create that sort of Atmosphere for
people and for them to be comfortable
with their bodies and establish those
boundaries and do it in a professional
way where that requires them to be
intimate I think it's important that
everybody understands that everyone else
has a as a a different set of boundaries
or interests or whatever and you'd be
respectful of that absolutely yeah a lot
of the
the
fetish
interviews I've done people have been
really
really great communicators and that
that's probably why they've been
successful in that lifestyle because
they
communicate well and they respect
people's boundaries and what they're
into and what they're not and it just
seems to be seems to work really well we
got to talk about it a lot yeah a lot of
talking sure it's a lot of I mean you
have to be I don't want to say like a
good communicator but you have to
communicate your boundaries or else
you're gonna get hurt or you're gonna
feel violated in some way or something
smaller situation for sure yeah there's
yeah miscommunications can happen and I
think um
the risk is higher right when you're
when we're working with that level of
intimacy
and so
I just burped um
tell me about the classes that you run I
mean what are you teaching people what
are you showing them what are you
doing impact or like well there's
there's usually two different types of
classes you have uh hard skills or soft
skills hard skills refers to like the
physical so that may be impact rope
um Electro Play Fire play wax like the
things that you see people doing it's
like the activity
and the second category of classes is
usually soft skills which is essentially
the the dynamic or the communication or
the um the interaction
the emotions the emotion the feelings
the thoughts
um between the parties that are involved
in in the activity and so um
that's the best way to kind of divide up
the two classes and then
from there it kind of depends on the
audience so sometimes it's a 101 you're
usually going to talk about the safety
behind something and then how to how to
sort of explore it within within those
safety protocols and then as you get
more familiar with it and you want to
explore more then you have more of like
um on a bell curve like edge cases
exploring that sort of activity 201 301
type stuff
when it comes to like soft skills
every 101 BDSM 101 class I've ever seen
is essentially just negotiations it's
like how to behave
and negotiate
and negotiations and that's basically it
it's that's a 101 in soft skill class
and what I think is so interesting is
the majority at least in my experience
so I I have experience in pretty much
all of California but like up and down
the West Coast Southwest area and then
Dallas wherever you want to put that in
your Geographic understanding of the
United States somewhere
um is that the majority of the classes
available in local spots are going to be
101. like those are your biggest money
earners and
everyone coming into the space who's
oftentimes new needs to know how to
behave so so many of those classes are
101. it isn't until you start going to
conferences that we start getting into
the more advanced classes or when you
start getting into
um
deepening relationship you know seminars
essentially is what a conference ends up
becoming sometimes
um
and that's that's what I found
fulfilling or gratifying for myself
what are what are the most common Mis
misunderstandings or or assumptions that
Outsiders would make about the fetish
community
which is not it's it's absolutely not
abuse like it's it's the the entire
Foundation of thinking BDSM is consent
and so it really just grinds my gears
when people are like oh this is abuse or
oh this is unethical I'm like no it's
not it's it's it becomes unethical if
something is unconsensual however
it's all based on consent and it's all
based on communication and boundaries
and negotiations so I just think it's
ridiculous that's why people are
involved in groups like FetLife yeah
there's an internet website for people
that have all these interests right it's
like kinky Facebook basically
no I totally agree that life is like a
concave
um
I think Fit Life with that being said I
think fit life is what you make it you
can go on there and you can add people
that you know that you've met and then
have a really wonderful experience doing
that
or you can go on vet life and not know
how to navigate it and add people you
don't know and then you could have uh
mixed results
yeah it's also toggling your settings is
definitely worth it
um because you know random people will
message you and be like hey I want to be
your daddy and you're like no thank you
I don't get those messages
are you are you looking for a daddy
I did get one recently though did you
yeah somebody wanted to wanted me to tie
them they wanted to learn a couple
things oh that's awesome yeah good what
kind of people do you get in the class
like newbies
all sorts yeah
at some point it becomes like especially
the organization I was a part of was
like a community center I mean there
were like three main ones one was like a
club sort of atmosphere one was a
community center which is the one I was
most involved with and the other one was
like a true like
CD Dungeon what is this I don't know
um
and so with that sometimes it just
becomes like a hangout spot like if
we're doing a class on on Fire play
even if there's someone really really
good they may go to the fireplace house
because they want to be around other
enthusiasts who are interested in
fireplace yeah because it becomes a
hangout yeah you know and these classes
aren't super expensive they're ranging
between 50 or 50 but like five dollars
to to 30 dollars just depends
um
and so yeah you get
people who are curious people who are
new people who have been in the scene
for a long time but want to try
something different you know they're
they want to explore another Avenue of
their Kink and then people who are very
well established or very knowledgeable
on the particular skill or topic who
just want to be around
uh people they share a common interests
like-minded people like-minded people
thank you yeah yeah
what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from
your time with this in this lifestyle
whoa
um I would say that advocating for
yourself has been a big one for me
um
because it made me realize how much a
lot of the time I would not advocate for
myself and it is something that I'm
still working on okay has it helped you
establish like better relationships
because a hundred percent like if you
were out in the
outside world where you're just on your
own and just it's a wild it's a wild
west out there yeah oh yeah absolutely
and um it seems like this community
could make it make your
relationship safer yeah 100 and
certainly more interesting yeah everyone
is very you know
consent focused communication focused
boundary focused and I think being in a
group of people who are like that has
made my mindset shift in a way that I'm
like oh I can also do this thing it's
not a huge scary thing to say no to
something like and
um I was given the opportunity now to
feel safe saying no
um which has been really valuable for me
I think yeah
absolutely
um for me it was being present one of
the things that like when you go in to
do a scene or the a play play scene
you have to be present for me I want to
have a connective experience with the
person I'm engaging with and
um
I didn't realize I thought it was an
interesting uh carryover because when I
got really really involved in the scene
my auditions got so much better I could
go and I could go into the room I had
like this whole mindset of like okay
this is me and then when I go into the
room to to do my audition I'm a whole
other person I'm living out of here for
acting yeah and then I was more present
when I was talking with a casting
director or acting and I was seeing
tremendous results from that
um
and so yeah I think being the scene
taught me a lot about being present uh
but the scene just it it connects with
so many different things right people
from all backgrounds come into this
activity or into this lifestyle
um whether it be people who have a sex
work background people who have
um
uh advocacy background but then you also
get people from Tantra you get people
from oh yeah cuddles you get people from
just a restorative justice yeah
um and you get to learn from all of them
those are all soft skills and hard
skills that really just add uh flavors
and different aspects into your life
um which I found to be very valuable and
the community is
for the most part
a
open-minded kind
of compassionate group or are there some
bad apples that you'll experience there
too
well I think I mean I think both those
statements are true I think for the most
part it's it's a very open and welcoming
space absolutely oh yeah
um there's very very few times I've
walked into a space that I was like oh
this is not uh this is not a great place
to be
um and if I ever had that feeling there
was usually another place in the same
similar vicinity that had a complete
opposite you know feeling that was
welcoming an opening so sometimes you do
have to try out a couple of venues if
there are some close by but um there's
also bad apples
you know it's everywhere it's just the
nature of Being Human it's the nature of
Being Human
um
and and that's tough those those
situations are tough
um
I think sometimes I've seen this a
couple of times where people want to
like gatekeep
the community whether it's you know
someone who's a masochist but then
someone else says like oh you're not
masochist enough oh I hate that I hate
that so much like a masochist is
somebody who enjoys pain it doesn't
matter the amount of pain or how hard or
how soft it is I think that's so cool
makes me so mad makes me so mad it's so
stupid I'm sorry so you can't so you do
get a bit of that from time to time
and at and at the same time though you
you can create your community within the
community that's right so if you end up
interacting with someone that you don't
like or you don't agree with there's
somebody else in that room or somebody
else close by or who's
you know within your vicinity of
influence
um
that you can have uh similar ideas with
and really create the space that you
want to be a part of
um yeah there's definitely somebody for
everybody
yeah it's not always uh accessible to
everyone right right that's just the the
nature of people who have
um money and you have property and
people who run organizations are in uh
you know positions of influence or power
right you can't expect
every single person to walk into a space
and feel welcomed in every Space by
everyone
and that's unfortunate
um but my hope is is as uh people begin
like as the general population the
vanilla world begins to explore their
sexual Freedom we get to have more
spaces like this to where we can create
at least a space for anyone to even if
it's not the same space but just any
space for anyone to be able to explore
that because I think it's really
important to who we are as people as
humans
yeah excellent cutter Penny thank you so
much for opening our minds a little bit
sure informing us and uh I wish you guys
all the luck in the world have have fun
thanks with your lifestyle thank you all
right thank you very much